[Musique]
il a traversé les décennies jean pierre
boyer ne se lasse pas de chanter l'amour
cette année il fête ses 40 ans de
carrière comme si le temps n'avait pas
de prise sur lui
nous allons retrouver ici chez lui à
leurs visages
la réunion
jugée l'arrivée
merci jean pierre boyer quel plaisir de
retrouver ou à saillé 40 ans de carrière
est-ce que tu as l'impression que vous
les inoxydables conseil fait toujours
chantal longpré celle de l'amour de la
chanson même sac lui même cette ce
métier et comme il dit même nom et puis
il faut l'utiliser au maximum et puis
c'est le public qui diamant la force si
toi c'est comme ça depuis des années
c'est le public mi aime son public et
ibm en main mais aussi et puis c'est mon
vitamine c mon public
on va commencer très jeune à faire de la
musique commence à la tire a ouvert la
musique qu'aux lazio ou envie de chanter
comme il était petit l'un me tiennent
pas trop l'école mais a toujours aimé la
musique
même s'il m'a pas fait seul fait je
m'appelle guitare et mais hook m je fais
la musique atta mills a fait le
bar-tabac mois ils m'arrêtent le
couillon intéressant tout simplement mai
puis mettez ça dans la peau me sentais
que mes tomates a gagné chanson à
l'époque avait une seule radio à
l'époque le rtf mais après je t'ai vu
rfo bain mais écoutez la radio sans
arrêt mais mais mais les beatles et et
les chansons de saxon et puis française
bien sûr et puis mettez en route et pas
par les voix des chanteurs de force et
bien sûr
autour y aller
vannes tout seul
les
journée jusque là commence au dollar
hier l'autre côté la mère 8 et comment
ça se passe et il m'était que j'offre ma
guitare la maison mais jouer le soir en
rentrant du boulot mais puis je me
consacre opposé la première chanson de
sétif il a et puis wade a misé la pire
des jeux tels maintenant si la main a vu
que m'avait dont le composé par ces deux
genres ton petit et camélia mais avait
dit mme avait dédié de musique ma tête
me suis même d'un compositeur de musique
et même du bonheur quelques choses en
main mais il faut y aller il fallait il
faut foncer vous rêve s'est réalisé et
on a eu du succès assez rapidement
rionnaise rayonner son fidèle en amitié
amour et avec leur short et bien c'est
peut-être ça aussi ils ont vu que il y
avait quelque chose en moi et puis ils
m'ont soutenu et c'est pour cela aussi
que mais qui est toujours la région
prenant 6 anicroche consécutif en vivant
enfants vivant en métropole c'était pour
moi c'est et j'avais du mal à réaliser
vous n'écoutez pas causé comme en mai
fais ce n'est pas ma passe quarante ans
de l'autre côté de la côte et en plus
mon travail de celui que l'ap-hp et il
me fit laissant même temps le soir et
péter kent évoqué ce chantier à orléans
avec un toupet de paris ou avec behnken
et tout beau tout ça mais c'est vrai
mais la fosse
tant les papas ton sans les mélanger qui
connaît bien
dans gmail
tentative l'appui
mais les époques avec wind de vos
chansons fait pas leurs oreilles
mais ça c'est parce que tu es vivent
là-bas que la spirale du label m'a vu
m'a vu sa tête personnes dont le rôle de
jack sock remettre à l'hôpital comme
chez des amis ou des gens qui
travaillent ce baiser rickroll blanc il
y dit pas ils sont ils sont ils sont
réunis et puis c'est les oreilles me
disent avec deux jours pied de simal ma
collègue s'était comporté indiqué
saddoun el mamri midi mais quand je vois
tu vois ça tu dis à temps et un problème
à l'école
attention départ
[Musique]
nous les revenus en 2012 à la réunion
avec toujours la même envie de chanter
dans les rues toungui bonjour prévoyez
dédicaces tout est là le gibbon non ça
va finir pas aller au plus près encore
deux autres corps ils veulent encore
définitif s'ils veulent donner encore et
peut-être parce qu'on parle bien d'amour
que les gens aiment ça tout le monde est
bien garni et il n'y pas que comme ils
sont là me choque pas mais ils sont peu
à tout le monde se retrouve dans mes
chansons
méchant tacle ok on s'est dit que tpiy
enfin faut dire aussi que j'aime j'aime
les femmes comme le mont olympe et
jamais la vie jamais gens gentils et
j'aime les gens sérieux
fidèle et jusqu'à quand vous viendrez
chanter mais moi j'ai dit baye temps -
la pêche la santé la voie que joue la
méchante l'hémicycle accumulant toujours
plus longtemps possible jusqu'à la mort
merci beaucoup jean pierre boilley mais
on en a ou encore longtemps
merci à tenir ces crédits